hey Doug Walker here I am going to be
talking about Disney's latest anime a
hit Moana and I'll address the first
thing that a lot of you have been
emailing me about yes I know they say
sparkle Sparkle Sparkle and is kind of
like my Thomas in the Tank Engine movie
review and a lot of you have been going
that represent the review the
referencing to review and then I saw
your name in the credits so something
must be referencing review I think I saw
Rob's name in there too
okay couple things one it seems very
unlikely the referencing me the scene is
like she's out there as a distraction
and for his monster that like sparkly
thing so she just goes look at me I'm
sparkly sparkle Sparkle Sparkle I feel
like that line would exist even without
should be referencing that and then in
terms of my name being in the credit my
name is actually been in most animated
Disney films as far as I know offence
Beauty and the Beast and my brothers uh
we have never worked there there just
happens to be two people I don't know if
they're related but there is a Doug
Walker and a Rob Walker that we actually
look for in the credits of these
animated Disney films because we we
spotted them once I think we saw Rob's
name it's like welcome in the credits
they were like oh well now we gotta look
for Doug's name and sure enough my name
was there too so it's just a coincidence
uh I don't think they're referencing me
when they're doing the sparkle Sparkle
Sparkle um but if they are this is one
of the greatest films ever made and it's
not it's a piece of crap don't go see it
so okay that got out of the way so you
can stop with the emails and everything
um but yeah most you know what this is
about this is a sur ho Lian folklore and
I don't know if that's a correct
terminology but definitely based on like
kawaii myths and then demigods and stuff
like that of this the several islands
and the worlds are being consumed by
some sort of evil because Maui has
stolen the heart of this island and
that's turned everything bad so Moana
the door of this chief eyes
sets out or if she sends herself out to
go and find Maui so that he can return
the heart which is the stone to the
island and make everything better again
I feel like I need to review this in two
ways I'll tell you why in a second the
one way I had to review is just what I
think the majority of people who want to
go see this movie are going to think and
then the other way is just what I
personally think in terms of like what
people the movie goers or people I love
Disney or love frozen Zootopia or any of
those they're going to think I think
they're going to like it great it's a
good family film and I say family not
kids you know kids are fine they can
watch in they'll totally enjoy it but
it's a good family some bears stuff for
adults as well you know that the
characters are likable there's the cute
little comic relief there's good songs
or hummable visually it's very
interesting there's a lot creativity to
it there's some good comedy to it so
this is a perfectly likable enjoyable
family film and I like that so much more
effort b-boying the family films and so
forth so that makes me very very happy
and I'm always glad when I can say a
good family film is out there and I
recommend it okay
now my thoughts uh you know that Disney
checklist that you feel with every
Disney movie you see and it's always
there you know ever since Snow White I
they altered it and changed a little bit
but it's always kind of been there I
felt that much more in this film than I
did some of the other ones that came out
like Zootopia and frozen and even kind
of big hero six in a sense um this movie
didn't the the probably buy hold it to
kind of this higher standard because you
know you always know this checklist but
I always kind of hold it to a little bit
of a higher standard because I really do
enjoy Disney and I'm always astounded by
them just what they are how they're
still around and how they're able to
turn out such good material
constantly with a very familiar formula
it's very repetitive formula honestly
but still enough new things that it
feels kind of like it feels kind of
different and it feels exciting and
inspiring and heartfelt and magical as
the were they always use and that always
intrigued me I'm so intrigued by that so
I think it's it's always good pointing
out when that's done so well that you
kind of don't notice that checklist uh
but then I think it is also worth
pointing out when it becomes maybe when
there's a lack of newer things in there
and that's always a complaint people say
well how its newer stuff do you want uh
its I want enough new stuff that it
distracts me from from that checklist I
think even kind of reference it there's
a scene where they're uh Maui is talking
to Moana and says well I get this right
this a princess comes along she says I'm
not a princess and he says you wear a
dress you have a comedic animal sidekick
your princess even they know the
checklist I mean they know even they're
having fun with it and that the mass
public kind of catches on to it too uh
and I feel like with this story and the
characters and everything even though
there's nothing bad I can't point to
anything in there and be like oh that
was bad this was not good everything is
good but there wasn't enough of like
kind of a spin or a there was enough
added to it compared to the other recent
films I've come out that made me say
alright this is exciting this is
thrilling that this is magical I sort of
got that I said this is fine this is
cute this is you know a nice little
adventure I never quite got for
something that I can tell was trying to
be really big and really massive and
really emotional and when those
emotional scenes hit I was not feeling
like wow I'm really with this character
I'm really with their dilemma and even
some of the comedy when you know I
thought with an audience of like kids
loved adults
and you know if they would laugh don't
get me wrong but compared to these other
movies these are a Disney films like
Zootopia they didn't laugh as hard um
and I think they could just kind of feel
like they know how this is supposed to
go that they know okay well we have to
hit this because it's the checklist you
know you can the point I knew where we I
was going to kind of have this problem
most likely was at the very beginning
you see the to give the backstory and
then you see Moana as this little little
kid and it's the best best part of the
movie by the way it's beginning and
ending up best visuals one you've seen
in the I think was like the Japanese
trailer or something like that where the
ocean is kind of just having fun with
the little toddler of her and like
nothing with her hair and doing it
that's amazing I mean that was just like
one of the best parts then the other
best fires at the very end
one of the final visuals after the
villains destroyed those who seem to
know what I'm talking about
unbelievable visual this is something
where it's like Disney World Disneyland
get on making this thing an attraction
or just somewhere where you can you know
just go and experience there is some
sort of sculpture I don't care you got
to get on this I mean cuz this just
looks amazing um so a like I said those
are seen the movie know what I'm talking
about
but yeah so they sort of is set her up
and they have this you know who she's a
traveler she's a wanderer but guess what
the father the chief says no there's no
traveling out there no going beyond the
great read no going here you are staying
here you're staying here how often have
you heard this I mean it is just a night
in Disney movies I mean you just sort of
see this over and over it's the
tradition we have to stay here we have
to be this and that's fine it's really
fine you know even the Pixar films and
stuff sort of repeat these ideas but it
takes hour add something new to it most
of the time and so does Disney uh but
this felt like the father's identity
while he was you know supportive and
kind and stuff he was just there to say
no you can't he was just there to be
proven wrong and then you have sort of
this comedic grandma
who again is for there to be the
comedian Graham and say you can do it
you can do it and like I said you just
go through the checklist of oh okay the
the other character whenever Maui who's
going to be full of themselves but he's
kind of likeable but he's going to be a
screw up and he's gonna make things
worse and at some point he's gonna feel
like he can't do it and things went
wrong he's gonna go away and say no
there's no chance and at some point he's
going to come back again we've seen that
but in those they always add either a
new twist or a new a new point of view
I guess just this new point of view on
this idea and then that's when they
going to get the point of view he like I
really don't think I'm ruining anything
by saying this uh he goes away thinking
he can't do it or thing he always lost
and I just comes back there is no reason
why he comes back they never explained
they never talked about even the reason
why he leaves is not very well set up so
it's one of those things where I kind of
felt like throughout this whole movie
they're kind of going through the
motions and there wasn't that much sort
of veering away from it with the
exception one or two things that that
weren't big enough for me that they felt
like they weren't different enough um to
give you an idea the comedic sidekick
you see him in the in the trailers
everywhere that little chicken with sort
of the wide eye whatever kind of like
the bird from finding dory the more I
think about it um but this chicken gets
dragged along now in most Disney films
there's always the comedic psychic but
they serve a purpose they do something
you know ah boo in Aladdin he would
steal things and he would help Aladdin
out and stuff like that you know in
frozen he gives the inspirational speech
at the end to help an out and stuff like
open the window you help do all this
stuff
this one does nothing absolutely nothing
and on top of that there is another
comedic sidekick that shows up in the
beginning completely disappears and then
shows up at the end it's that pig yeah
remember that pig like after the movie
was done my wife leaves up from uses boy
the pink sure got the shaft
then he isn't even a he we don't even
know a he or she
um maybe they said but it wasn't on long
enough for us to know and so much of the
film sort of felt like them the same
thing with the villain which you know
with they can take a while to get to it
but once you do see the villain is
counting oh let's need for a little bit
and let me see where they're going with
its like okay I maybe I can see why you
can't kept a secret but man what you
could have done with the villain
especially when you find out what the
villain is and you know sort of the
emotions there and everything when you
finally get to the defeat of the villain
a casual thing doing anything away when
you get to the defeat of the villain uh
they're trying to make it very big and
very emotional and visually it's not bad
but the emotions weren't there because
Moana and Maui are these archetypes that
we've seen a lot you know she just wants
to travel if she wants to see the world
but she told no but she's going to go do
it anyway with the help of her
supportive grandma that says calico and
gogo and she goes and discovers
everything but you know she's in a
little over her head so she has to find
a way to you know still be proud and
strong but goof up every once in a while
and then she comes across Maui you
always got the one eyebrow up you know
and he's always sort of full of himself
and it's just it's even his lesson
learned at the end he's the one that
caused everything in this movie really
screws everything up and he just
forgives a little apology at the end and
it just means so little it does not mean
a great big deal and even when he's
going there you don't feel like he's
going there because he really messed
things up and he needs to find a way to
make things right you know he's just
going because of this I feel I might be
a hero again I want to be a hero and
yeah it just you do not feel the
emotional weight of this um and I do say
has a problem but again I see it as a
problem for Disney because I do judge
Disney so harshly and I I do look at
these things and how can we
make it better how can we make it
stronger how can we get you know another
Toy Story another frozen another tangle
you know that all these movies that just
have you know are just so massive and so
impressive so if you're just looking for
a fun adventure a fun family adventure
you'll like this fine even if you have
kind of a critical mind like I do you'll
definitely get stuff out of it
Oh oh my god I forgot to mention this
I'm sorry I'm cuz I guess I was going to
mention this is talking about the the
formula you know and the checklist and
stuff like that there is one scene I
just don't know what the hell was going
on it's where they see this turtle it's
this giant turtle and it's I guess it's
funny but it's so weird it is beyond
crazy
odd and just the pacing changes and the
style the look of it changes just
everything in the movie kind of changes
when this turtle shows up on screen and
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
sometimes it go scary sometimes it goes
really just laughably weird or silly uh
and it is just the most bizarre thing so
yeah I just had to bring that up because
the rest of the film can't seems like
this one note that you're familiar with
then there's this water hell moment and
then back to that one um so yeah aside
from that scene which again I don't even
know if I can say it's like you know
yeah that was well done I don't know
what it was it kept my attention I was
definitely like oh was a again my wife
was saying like hey the song seemed
weird all the other songs and was kind
of nice and had this nice melody like
that one just seemed like it had like a
melody then be interrupted and another
melody will come in and it would kind of
work backwards and it was so bizarre uh
so there's that scene that's very very
desired turtle team but I wanted to
guess it was a very bizarre um so yeah
that kind of my take on the movie and
like I still recommend it I still say go
see if for any other reason the movies
I've often said I think are okay people
love I think I said big hero 6 was okay
help you was a little better than okay
but yeah people I mean those are huge
it's and people just adore them and they
dress up like the characters and stuff
they say the big impact so I mean is
definitely I still really recommend it
because if I think it's okay you're
probably going to think it's like really
really good um so yeah that's about it
and like I said my big problem is that I
just felt like there could be a few more
twists a few more surprises I kind of
felt like I knew where it's all going to
go and visually you know the Hawaiian
Islands are very pretty but it wasn't
grabbing me wasn't like wow look at this
incredible visual again except for the
very beginning and the very end abut
that's just me that's just kind of my
take on it I think it's a perfectly fine
enjoyable family film I think kids can
see it I think adults can see it and
everybody can get something out of it um
Fiji again is a joke I think they have a
they have a peeing in the river thing
which you don't see they just kind of
say and it's like that makes it PG there
is no reason to have it be PG there
really isn't so any parent that's afraid
to take their kid or anything really
creepy it's not it's a pee joke that's I
think about it I can't remember anything
else but yeah that's about it definitely
go check it out tell me what you think -
I'm curious if this is another one of
those where everyone's like how do you
think it's only okay and you know kind
of thing or if other people are like or
maybe even don't like it um it's not for
me to see someone like not liking it
like getting nothing out of it because
it is still pretty creative but yeah let
me know what you think below I'm
actually really really curious to see
what people took from this film if they
took a lot from it or didn't take a lot
from it or if it offended them from how
I have no idea so um yeah that's about
it
people and I will see you next time take
care